quinze mille soldats mobilisés pour
protéger les institutions
gouvernementales dans un pays assiégée
et qu'ils se reposent dans les couloirs
du congrès avant une éventuelle attaque
ce véritable scénario digne d'un film
d'action de hollywood est en fait la
sombre réalité de washington détecteurs
de métaux au capitole l'installation de
clôtures partout en ville les autorités
redoublent de moyens pour éviter tout
débordement avec d'autres milliers de
policiers prêts à réagir
d'heure en heure la capitale américaine
devient une forteresse comme n'en n'ont
jamais vu les résidants à laval
je suis terrifiée par les partisans de
trump dit-elle ces gens ont des armes
beaucoup d'armes dans les capitales
d'état on se prépare aussi au cas où du
oui ce concert au mississippi en passant
par le minnesota on craint le pire
les menaces sur le web dit le gouverneur
du minnesota se matérialisent maintenant
dans la réalité mais contre qui faut-il
se préparer alors que les arrestations
se multiplient un peu partout
il est encore difficile de cerner le
niveau d'organisation de ces individus
qui étaient prêts à renverser un
gouvernement et les groupes sont très
nombreux et leur idéologie sont
différentes explique alex frei de feo et
depuis la purge des comptes d'extrême
droite et de complotiste la surveillance
de ces groupes est plus compliqué être
dans le groupe
il est possible qu'il soit en train de
planifier des choses en utilisant des
applications sont cryptés difficile à
intercepter ceux qui traquent ces
groupes sur internet estime que les
agences gouvernementales font ce
qu'elles peuvent pour éviter de tels
tragique événement la prévention c'est
bien mais certains principes viennent
affaiblir ce travail selon ibrahim
hooper
où s'arrête la liberté de parole dit il
et où commence la conspiration pour
commettre un crime
lorsque ces groupes ont défilé dans les
rues ils l'ont fait pour manifester
contre le congrès mais certains d'entre
eux étaient bien organisés avec une idée
précise
en prenant d'assaut le capitole si l'on
en juge par l'arsenal impressionnant de
mesures de sécurité mises en place ici
des mouvements de foule et
d'insurrections sont beaucoup moins
probable que le 6 janvier mais les
autorités n'ont plus le luxe de laisser
passer quoi que ce soit le monde entier
a les yeux rivés sur la capitale et sur
la santé de la démocratie américaine
ici frédéric arnold radio-canada
washington